police in Austin Texas are investigating
the fourth mysterious explosion this
month the latest blast last night
injured two men in their 20s dozens of
law enforcement officials blocked off a
residential neighborhood overnight as
they searched for clues this morning
nearby residents are being asked to stay
inside today investigators say it's
possible that yesterday's explosion in
southwest Austin was triggered by a
tripwire three earlier package bombs
killed two people and injured two others
police say they believe that last
night's explosion is connected Omar
Villafranca is near the scene in Austin
Omar good morning good morning we're
about a quarter mile from yesterday's
explosion it's actually just down this
street there's some vehicles that are
starting to show up there some more
investigators are getting here this
morning that's just down the street
heavy police presence here in this
neighborhood and if you don't believe me
you can see a lot of the lights here the
entrances are all blocked here no one in
no one out
residents are on a virtual lockdown and
they're doing that because they're still
investigating the blast site right now
and they're also trying to make sure
that there are no more explosives in
this neighborhood
law enforcement including federal agents
from the FBI and ATF flooded a normally
quiet neighborhood in southwest Austin
overnight police believe a bomb left on
the side of the road exploded injuring
two people it is very possible that this
device was a device that was activated
by someone either handling kicking or
coming in contact with a tripwire the
awesome interim police chief brian manly
said investigators were checking a
second item a backpack near the scene of
the first blast and warned people to
stay away from anything suspicious pay
attention to any suspicious device
whether it be a package a bag a backpack
earlier this month three package bombs
were left on porches in East Austin all
three exploded killing two people and
severely injuring two others all the
victims were black or Hispanic assisting
Austin police are over 500 federal
officials by Sunday afternoon 735
suspicious packages were reported 435
leads were called in and 236 people had
been interviewed a reward for
information has risen to over $100,000
Manly held a press conference before
Sunday's explosion to directly address
whoever is responsible
we hope this person or persons is
watching and will reach out to us before
anyone else is injured or anyone else is
killed police say the two men who were
injured were on a bike they were either
riding their bikes or they were walking
them when that explosion was triggered
that is new the good news though is
there they are hospitalized and they are
in good condition investigators are also
telling us that the residents in this
neighborhood are not going to be able to
get out of their homes till at least
daylight the earliest 10 a.m.
Gale hopefully won't take too long to
catch who's ever responsible thank you
very much Omar